[Music]
on today's show we talked to an awesome
dad who wants to have some hard
conversations with his sons about their
mom who recently passed away
we're going to talk to an awesome
awesome young mom who is struggling with
loving her body after miscarriages and
we're going to talk to
a young man who loves his sister but
they're estranged
and she wants them to donate a kidney
stay tuned
hey good folks what's up it's delony and
this is the dr
john deloney show a show for you about
you
about your marriages your life your
friendships
that frustrating annoying person you see
in the mirror
your parents all of it we're talking
about everything on the show and if
you're new to our band of ninjas we
we cover everything mental health issues
school issues
parenting relationships marriages should
i get married should i not
brother and sister questions all of it
i want you to know that you're not by
yourself you're not alone i am trying to
figure this out with you
and one commitment that we all have is
that we tell the truth on the show
and we walk together and so i don't want
people walking through life feeling like
they're all alone because there are
millions of people
just like you with the same concerns the
same frustrations the same questions the
same
i don't know what to do next going
through their mind just rattling around
in there like a
like one of those little rubber bouncy
balls you got at the at the quarter
turn vending machines there at the mr
gaddy's when you're a kid right
that just dated me by about 300 years
right but
we want you to know you're not alone i
want you to know you're not by yourself
and so we're here for you give me a call
one eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one one
eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one or go to johndaloni.com
show you can fill out the form it goes
right to kelly
and as she puts the shows together
she'll reach out to you and see about
having you on
a couple of things i want to talk
through real quick number one
i've been getting some emails about um
well hold on before you do that there's
like a studio audience man look at
everybody it's so great to see good
folks some are are better looking than
others
right but everybody i'm so glad to see
you guys so i'm
getting emails about not being able to
tell
when i'm being sarcastic and when i'm
not and there was this awesome
moment when um i had a boss that i that
i worked for
and we were going to this really fancy
dinner and she always wanted me to sit
next to her
and my wife was coming to this one so
she was my wife sitting on the other
side of us
and i said something during the dinner
and my boss looked at me
and she said i do not know when you are
being serious are you being sarcastic i
can't tell the difference so from this
point forward you will declare
this is a joke or this is serious period
and my wife leans over and goes
oh my thank god finally so listen
if you think in your head it's it's the
hatchet rule
if you like i used to tell parents the
psychologist
a kid would call him and be like hey mom
guess what my r.a was chasing me down
the hall with a hatchet saying he was
going to murder me
and the parent would think to themself
there's no way that happened but then
they would call me and they would send
me really mean
cards and letters talking about i can't
believe that i'm sending my kid to your
college where they
chased people down with hatchets and
then i would call the parent and i would
say
seriously do you really believe that
that happened
and they would go ah probably not and i
would say
god almighty no no one is trying to kill
your kid with a hatchet here we want
your money
over and over and over again and so it's
the hatchet rule man if i say something
on this show and you think
i probably wasn't serious about that
then i probably wasn't serious about
that
and if i have an emphatic point to make
so much that like spit comes out of my
mouth just like just happened
then i will make an emphatic point but
i try not to be sarcastic but it just
happens sometimes i just think life's a
lot of fun let's have a good time
together
here's the second thing i'm going to be
a part of a live event with my good
friend rachel cruz
she works here with me um she is
very very fancy has a best-selling book
that just came out
um here's the deal we are doing an event
together on wednesday
january 20th and no no that's the call
the event is february 12th
good gosh i'm recording it today
friday february 12th it's our marriage
and money livestream event
right these are for marriages all across
the country that are feeling the weight
of 2020 and the 2021 is going to be so
awesome and so far it is not delivering
right
and so the financial strain has turned
everything upside down
so we are doing an event it's a money
and marriage livestream event
we're gonna share what we've learned
through walking alongside couples for
two decades we're going to help you fall
in love all over again
have more fun in your marriage take care
of your money one of the
main stressors for marriages and it's
going to be a blast so early bird passes
for the live stream are on sale now
it's just 20 bucks they won't last long
so head over to daveramsey.com
events to buy your ticket
and i was gonna say one more thing we
won't let's just go straight to the
calls let's get to
tom in dallas brother tom what's going
on man how can i help
well thanks sean um love what you do
uh for ramsey and just been a listener
ever since you got on
uh love what you're doing thank you well
man i appreciate you good man so how can
i help you today
so um my late wife had some compulsive
behaviors
and i'm concerned that my sons who are
24 18 and 14
may have unknowingly picked them up by
watching or living in the house with
these behaviors
you know more has cost and taught things
how do i share
with them and try to warn them about
these behaviors
without hurting the memory of their late
mom oh man tom that's a great question
um when she when did she pass away uh
about two years ago about two years ago
how are you man i'm good
i'm good uh i'm a christian and
you know i got a great church family
around me and i've got
great uh brothers and sisters and my
family's been supportive
and my boss at work
every everybody's been super supportive
um
it's while it's a horrible thing to go
through
um i can't imagine it being
any better on this side well i'm
i'm grateful that that's that you've had
that that
sort of community and care around you
through this time that's awesome man
so what talk to me about the compulsive
behaviors what do you mean by that
um that can mean a whole different a
whole arc of of different things what do
you mean
when we uh spending money freely
um after our first son was born she
battled postpartum
and finally got on we were in a bad
economic situation that was my fault not
hers
we got more stable moved to a different
area she found a doctor got on
medication did a little counseling
through the years
but not anything real consistent about
11 years before she died she fell on a
concrete floor
and blew her back out when she at that
point she started having to take heavy
um pain meds for that okay she had
she had basically 11
different surgeries most of which were
unrelated to the back
over her last 10 or 12 years of her life
so what behaviors are your kids or your
sons
like what are they exhibiting that makes
you concerned that
they pick some stuff up or are you
trying to be proactive
i'm trying to be mainly proactive i mean
my oldest son he's
he's married he's moved out but he's
you know we didn't drink um and
uh that that was just the way it was
that we told him
you do what you want when you're an
adult in our house that's that's a rule
and they all knew it and and i'm
concerned
that maybe he since he didn't see
any we she never drank but
since he didn't have that fence okay
this is as far as you go with this and
don't go over it
um he may not know where that fence is
for him
okay and he go and go and go and then
the 18 year old and 14 year old they're
coming
up and i just it you know you're a
single parent so
you try to do everything that you
possibly can and
you feel like you screwed up everything
right so this is
one thing left i i think maybe i can i
can help them with before they get out
on their own
so to ease any sort of anxiety you have
there's a hundred percent chance you've
screwed things up and that's okay
cool thanks sean okay good good
so um we all have man and
we are just contributing to the future
counselors of america right
so the fact that you're asking this
question as you that you were trying to
look
down the road and almost reverse
engineer
some challenges your kids may encounter
because some things they may have seen
in your house tells me you're a great
dad
and you're a compassionate guy and these
three boys are lucky to have you
okay just the fact that that question is
in your head
so many people who experience the loss
of a loved one
of a spouse in particular just
begin to loop for years and years on me
me me
my love my next step my financial
situation and so on and so forth so the
fact that you are concerned about them
is
is noble um here's the deal man
none of us are perfect and every single
person myself included have skeletons in
our closet have things that i would love
to have done
like i would love to have a chance to do
over with my kids and
and vice versa and there's things that
my wife does i think
man i would not have handled it like
that and i can say that because she
doesn't listen to this podcast ever
and vice versa right i know there's
things because she's called me out on it
appropriately so that she says hey
let's don't do it that way let's why
don't you talk to him like this or
another way right
so telling the truth and talking about
your wife
in a compassionate informative and
memorial
way to your kids that is informative to
them that is telling them hey here's
some
some things you're going to navigate
along the way man that's good
stuff that's family history stuff that
is rich
it's when you start telling them things
to prop
you up to make excuses for why you did
what you did
to um to name throat
to diminish her that's when it becomes a
problem
talking about her challenges that she
had
i think is great what you mentioned
something that i think
would be a great place to start it would
be a time with dad with each one of
your sons individually and just letting
them
talk to you talk about their experience
with mom what do they remember
what do they remember about their
childhood and then make it perfectly
clear
that they are always always always
welcome to ask you
questions no matter how hard no matter
how invasive no matter how
vulnerable and you may want to bring a
couple of things to the table to commit
to to them
and let them know hey here's a couple of
things i wish i could have done
done differently hey we didn't ever have
alcohol in the house
and just so you know seven's too much
right just nine beers is a lot
17 beers you're going to want to dial it
back a few right whatever you feel like
you need to talk to them about
lead with vulnerability there give them
a chance to ask questions and here's
what you want to do
your 14 year old isn't going to be able
to verbalize all of the stuff that
you're thinking about right now
and if you started if he starts
exhibiting behaviors and you say well
your mom
he's not able to absorb that what you
want to do is to create such a
safe and welcoming and
vulnerable relationship with him that
when he does start to ask questions he
comes to you first
and again i keep saying the same thing
only way a dad does that is by going
first
um your older two sons yeah man sit down
and have a hard conversation with them
or a beautiful
engaged conversation with them i don't
think it has to be hard um
was there any sort of abuse that that
was back there is there something
lingering that's big that you need to
feel like you need to address
no no she was um she was as good a mom
as she
she could be i mean anybody with chronic
pain
and chronic depression i mean she
she was uh she was great that's that's
she did she was there for the boys as
much as humanly possible
probably more than a lot of women would
have been in her situation but
no it just the whole have you ever had
that conversation
with them tom no i have not
i think that is like just each one of
them by themselves i'm just thinking
about this now and i could get choked up
pretty quick
thinking of my dad taking me out and
just
saying hey i just need to have a
conversation with you just mono imano
um mom hurt a long time and i need you
to know
how much she loved you yeah
and we have had conversations man you
will give that's a gift they will carry
with them for the rest of their life
so i again going back to
lead with vulnerability tom you go first
and anything you talk about that's going
to give them tools and insights
that's going to make their life easier
make their journey easier
and give them some insight as to why
they're doing what they're doing
that caught as taught is not
deterministic it is not
inevitable right just because kids see a
thing doesn't mean it's going to become
a thing
and then they're gonna have to live with
it forever but it is good information
for folks to know
right um but yeah go first
you're a good dad tom i'm glad to have
gotten to talk to you today
and i'm glad we got to start our show
off with a texas caller that's awesome
all right let's go to vivian in
bloomington illinois
vivian what's going on how can i help
hello dr dalony thank you so much for
taking my call i'm just honored to be
speaking with you
dude the honor is all mine vivian so how
can i help
um my question is how do i stop
negative and hateful feelings i have
towards my body after multiple
miscarriages
and infertility struggles
that one's tough vivian wow thank you
for your trust there
so walk us back through your journey so
far
um so i grew up in a really big family
my parents
had ten kids together so i had nine
siblings um and my mom was just
an absolute rock star she had all of us
at home zero painkiller
she would literally like sing and she
gave birth
she was just incredible and did you say
she was singing
yes you know what because why not man
we're just going to take this and pile
up on poor vivian right aren't golly
okay um she was she was amazing though
and she would talk about you know
the amazing design of a woman's body and
and i always just had a profound respect
for my own body and um
so kind of fast forwarding my husband
and i
got married and we got pregnant right
away we have a beautiful four-year-old
and i think unknowingly it just kind of
confirmed because i have a lot of
sisters who've had a lot of kids
kind of not easily but you know just
gotten pregnant quickly and
it just kind of confirmed to me that you
know this will be a breeze and
um and so then um
a while later when we were ready to try
for a second um
i noticed it was taking a long time and
i thought that was weird
and then when i did get pregnant i
miscarried which the first one was just
very jarring i think i was just shocked
that that happened to me
um and then we tried again after many
many months and i became
pregnant again and we thought everything
was fine
that time and i miscarried almost at the
end of that
first trimester so i just
i just struggle so much to i feel like
as much of a profound respect
that i used to have for my body i have
an equally profound
disrespect and um frustration
and yeah i'm just not sure how to
how did you um and again at any point
you say hey
i'm done talking about that part um just
cut me off okay i want you to know
your control the conversation here um
how did you grieve
those miscarriages how did you and your
husband do that together
um it's interesting um because i think
i think i've grieved the loss of like
knowing that i'll never know who they
were um you know what they would be like
their hair color all cried and cried
and just kind of kind of came to a place
um
of acceptance with that and i think what
i haven't i think
you said it or somebody said that grief
is not just crying a lot it's
um ownership and i think i have not
owned
that i struggle with fertility um like
one of my close friends said something
to me the other day like you know how
are you doing with your infertility
struggles and i
my internal reaction was like i don't
have infertility struggles like
it's been for years how about you go
drown yourself right yeah
yeah wonderful and she's very
well-meaning and hasn't been through it
but
sure um but yeah so i i think i have not
grieved that and i think sometimes you
know my husband's wonderful and
very emotionally available um but i
think i just always worry that i'm
bothering him and so i kind of
will just go off and deal with it myself
sometime
when i think he wants to be there for me
so i'm gonna answer the best i can
okay having had a ringside seat to this
but not a driver's side seat okay
and i've talked about some of
our my family's challenges publicly and
some of that stuff i'll keep private
and i'll go to the grave with it and
other stuff i think it can be helpful to
talk about
and also i'm gonna answer your question
vivian to
a wide audience okay so i'll speak to
you directly but also speak
a broader conversation and let's start
with
you and your husband's conversation so
um when we experienced this in my house
with the lion's share of the the pain
resting in my wife
and in her heart um i was working crisis
for the city and so when things went
down in the city i was on a team they
got called out to go help other people
in their worst moments
i was also the dean of students at a
university and i helped students in
their worst moments
and i was working on a second phd in
counseling and a partridge in a pear
tree
long story short if it was going down
chances are they were going to call
delony to come in and help
and then we had a series of challenges
like this in my own home
and i handled it terribly
i had a lot of information i had a lot
of you know what you should be doing
and i missed it completely and i'll
never forget going to a counseling
conference
and i walked into the room and one of
the sessions was
counseling women who've been had um
miscarriages infertility challenges
and as shameful as this is i was saying
it out loud
um the thought in my head is was
oh i know how to do that because i've
you know i've experienced that i know
how to do that
and then shame on top of shame on top of
shame this is like an embarrassing
moment for me like a heartbreaking
moment for me that i was just arrogant
but i actually thought i could probably
help in the presentation
so i'll be one of those people in the
audience that helps out the presenter
and during the presentation the
presenter proceeded to say hey
we know we all know this and she said it
so flippantly i'll never forget it
there's like seven things you never ever
say to a woman who's experienced this
and by the time she got to five and six
and seven
vivian not only had i said all seven of
those things but i had expounded on him
i had
was was like running my mouth about him
in our house
with this with this sense of arrogance
and it was one of the most humbling
humiliating shameful moments of my life
because i was just wrong there was one
person on planet earth that i swore
to be there for and it was my wife and i
wasn't
because um i was so arrogant and i was
just trying to get there with
information and i wasn't
with and it was when we had some hard
conversations that
that where she really felt um free to
open up that i realized oh my god
almighty i missed it a lot and so what i
would challenge you
before you do anything else is to find
some safe time with your husband
and let him know what's going on in your
heart it will create a division
and a break in your relationship that
will take years to repair
and so um honor him with that and
challenge him with that
but start connecting with him there okay
and so
then here's the back out right i've
heard and again since that moment it was
a humbling moment you've probably heard
me say a million times on this show and
i'll keep saying it
telling guys to shut their stupid mouths
and to connect with people and don't
over
analyze and don't over inform people a
lot of that starts from that moment with
me right
so i've heard these things um throughout
time i've heard
i've been having periods since i was 12
and when it's go time
now you decide to not work i've heard
that i've heard throughout history
women's
women have been recognized and this is
thousands of years right
as a basically a tool for other people
for men to carry on legacy for
um men to have their babies grow to be
fed and on and on
is this this idea that women are always
apologizing for
how their body looks how it works is it
working well is it not working well
and it's exhausting i've heard
women describe how the pain and trying
to
explain to grandparents and in-laws
and their own parents and their husbands
i i want to give you grandkids i'm sorry
that we can't do this we had this plan
and it's not working out
um i had one buddy of mine tell me about
just walking down that hallway
and looking in that empty room that
there was plans for that empty room
and um i've heard heavy heavy things
the most profound view that has stuck
with me that i'll pass along to you
vivian is this idea of
being betrayed by my own body and it
sounds like you're you're familiar with
that one does that one ring true with
you
yes very much so like you man you were
raised with an awesome
well your mom's not fair number one
that's like your dad being michael
jordan
and you going out for the high school
team right um
but you know this idea that
the way it was framed the way it was
told to me and i loved it was
it's like your husband cheated on you
and you don't get the chance to leave
and there's nothing you you don't get to
talk about working it out and he doesn't
get to change his behavior because it
just is
so you have this betrayal and it rests
inside of you
and there's not a lot you can do about
except going to the next day and the
next day and the next day
does that sound right yes so give us an
example of
when when you have a dark morning a dark
um evening what's the self-talk there
um like if i ask for because i do a lot
my husband works
a lot more than i do i work from home
and part-time
so i take care of a lot of the household
stuff as i feel it should be
and if i ask for anything like any kind
of help with our daughter sometimes i'll
like step in and do it myself because
i'll be like you know thinking about my
sister that has five kids and like how
pathetic that i would
need help with our one there's just
things like that like i'm not allowed to
be
tired or you know this age she's four so
lots of questions and sometimes i'm like
i'm just tired you know
and then i'll be like wow how are you
tired you have one child that's pathetic
you know and just just anything
yeah just that kind of thing so if you
do
if you get nothing else out of this call
can will you promise me that you'll
start talking to my friend vivian
kinder yes
okay i want you to talk to vivian like
the rockstar mom that she is
and you got a beautiful four-year-old
and you have an awesome husband and
you've got a um an extraordinary gift
for empathy and for feeling and for
connecting with other people now and
that starts with you connecting and
being empathetic with yourself okay
is that a promise yes awesome
all right so here's the hard part
um you're gonna have to go through a
process of forgiveness
a friend of mine she went as far as to
name her uterus and of course she named
it after a man because why not
but she literally went through a process
of forgiveness
named it and got a group of people
around her
that she could talk with but had to go
through the process
of forgiving her own body and that
sounds weird and that sounds awkward
whether that's writing in a letter
whether that
is or writing your yourself your body a
letter
um but the idea of not forgiving this
is you are poisoning yourself from the
inside out
and you are wearing this chemical
response you're wearing this frustrating
frustration response
and it just gets heavy and eventually
your body goes to war with you
right and so you've got to be
about forgiving your body for not living
up to what you think it should have to
the expectations you put on it to the
quote unquote beautiful
machinery that you were given right then
the second thing is
this is hard but there's always going to
be an ache there
and it's as time goes on as you grieve
it
you're going to make peace with that
ache and then you're going to learn and
give in to celebrating others right it's
hard when your
sorority sister texts everybody and says
guess what guess what right or they send
that cute little instagram thing
that still sucks doesn't it yeah yeah
yeah it's some as
you're gonna have to lean into those
moments and practice
gratitude and practice celebrating other
people as hard and ugly as that will be
and then i really want you to explore
the story of motherhood in your heart
and
in your home and with your husband and
you've traced it you've done an awesome
job of tracing all the way back to
the the example that your extraordinary
mom set and the way she
talked about how beautiful your body was
and this extraordinary appreciation for
how your body works
you're gonna have to get beneath that
and ask yourself questions about do you
wanna be a mom
do you wanna have five kids running
around does that mean you're gonna go
through the adoption process does that
mean you are going to
you really just want to be a mom if
you're biological kid so you're going to
be a mom and the best aunt that's ever
been
you're going to foster you need to have
those type of conversations as you begin
to make meaning of
well then what is going to be next and
those are
not things you need to do by yourself
okay you got to have a community around
you
please please please please involve your
husband in those conversations
and then the last hard hard part of this
is you have to decide if you're going to
be vulnerable again
and nobody in the entire world can make
that decision except for you
and are you going to exhale
and then go again are you going to
say i'm done with the hurt and we are
blessed with the child that we've got
and then we're gonna start exploring
what family means for us down the road
um i'm confident you've already had
those thoughts where are you leaning on
the vulnerability
um do you mean like as far as trying
again or like talking with my husband
um i do think we we want to in the
future
um i think some of this is probably
coming up too because we
were not trying um currently because we
have a move possibly coming up and
i just feel like my daughter is getting
older and there's not a sibling
um and so that's been kind of
sad but um i do think we do want to try
in the future but just maybe not right
now awesome
and you're telling yourself a lot of
stories
about how your kids are feeling and how
your daughter's absorbing this
and how your husband's gonna respond
don't get in the head of other people
and begin
trying to solve problems for them that
they haven't communicated to you
okay you've got enough to carry and it's
hard
and yours your heart and soul is so good
that you are
you want to care for everybody around
you and in the process
you're going to end up drowning yourself
you're going to end up bringing carry
drop
carrying so much weight that um
it brings you down and those stories
that you're telling about your daughter
man your daughter's gonna be awesome
whether she has a
biological sibling 10 biological
siblings or if it's just the three of
y'all then y'all ride or die together
she's got an awesome mom and a great dad
she's going to be a great cousin you're
going to be a great hand all of those
things work together
but it starts with you having a moment
or a season of forgiveness for the body
that's betrayed you
and then it begins a reframing for
what's this body gonna
gonna how's this body going to support
moving forward
and then what's family going to look
like in our home vivian it sucks i hate
that this is happening to you
and um i know that there are millions
and millions of women
in the country who are experiencing and
all over the world experiencing exactly
what you're going through
and there's millions of husbands sitting
next to wives just like this
going i'm hurting too and i don't know
how to hurt i don't know what to say i
don't know how to say it
and so um start there with your husband
have that conversation
and then y'all can lean into the
forgiveness process and
let me know how those conversations go
and we will be thinking about you all
right let's ride one more let's go to
adrien
in anchorage alaska adrian what's going
on
how's it going dr d thanks for taking my
call all right brother thanks for
calling man so is it
i'm going to take a wild guess cold
no it's warm today 35 degrees
listen man if it was 35 in nashville the
city would shut down
everyone just quits um
it's warm today it's august baby it's
35.
all right man that sounds awful to me
anyway go ahead adrian what's going on
how can i help well
i have uh i have a sister who was
diagnosed with diabetes when she was two
years old
and now she's 31
has two kids is in kidney failure
um she is
with the same blood type and basically
i'm i'm just i go back and forth on
whether or not
i want to go through with the process of
trying to give her one of my kidneys
oh man okay so you've been confirmed
that you can be a donor huh so walk me
through your thought process
well um you know at a young age
my family was told she was told that
she she couldn't have kids she shouldn't
have kids it would
significantly impact the uh just the
her life expectancy and it could be
problematic for the children as well
um and two kids later i mean that's
exactly where we are
um she's just i just struggle with it
because she's somebody who hasn't really
taken care of herself the best
that she could and my concerns are
you know if if i if i do this is is it
something that she's going to be willing
to do for the rest of her life is
actually
take care of herself and and and do the
things that's going to be necessary for
the rest of her life in order to
to you know maximize what's going on
as long as you know the impacts that it
has on my life you know
i married myself and i'm
we're working on having kids and you
know
having just the the whole dynamic of
everything it just it makes me go back
and forth um
and on top of that i'm just i'm getting
now i'm getting pressure from my my
mother of course
and hey so so listen brother
don't
don't don't punish your sister don't use
your sister's
behavior to weigh in on your decision
here
and i know that might sound
counter-intuitive um
but man getting getting diagnosed as a
young kid with a
with a challenging medical condition
that you got to manage and deal with
that level of trauma and the concern and
stress that everyone has around you it's
not an excuse but it's a context for a
tough life for a little kid
what i don't want you to get into a a
either or
like i'll give it to you but you're
gonna have to man you are gonna make
yourself
insane you're gonna sever that
relationship whatever is left of it
and you're gonna go nuts this is a
decision for you
not for her and i know that sounds crazy
to sound because she lives
if you give her a kidney right
but it sounds like in your head if i'm
reading the tea leaves here
you almost can't not you're that kind of
guy is that right
correct there you go and so it's
almost not whether it can't be about
whether she's worth it
she's your sister of course she's worth
it right and you can come up with all
sorts of reasons why you don't want to
why it's scary why it's frustrating why
it's terrifying all those things
man and they're all real but the
question is
like if you can step up and help right
now are you going to are you not going
to
yes that's what i'm asking are you gonna
do it are you not going to because i
think you already know the answer bro
yeah um i mean i
i feel like i don't have a choice so yes
i i guess
will you do me a favor though i think
you're right i think you don't have a
choice
but i think the temptation is going to
be to blame that lack of choice on your
sister
it's going to be to blame that on your
mom and i want you to take
ownership of it because that's the
caliber of person that you are
similar to if i was walking home tonight
and there's a little kid playing in the
road and a car is coming
i can't not move that kid out of the way
i can blame the driver i can blame the
kid but the reality is you knew
i should blame my dad because he raised
me to take care of the little children
in my neighborhood
he raised me to step into hard
situations and that's where you found
yourself
and so when it comes to having kids man
i think the way to think about it is do
you want to
be the dad of kids and they know
oh yeah you know the ends of earth's the
ends of the earth my dad will go for you
he gave his kidneys to his sister he
literally gave a body part to somebody
that he didn't even have a great
relationship with
that's the kind of man my dad is
versus is it going to impact some stuff
i'm sure it will
i don't i don't know enough about organ
donation um
and the aftermath but i'm confident it
will impact things here and there
but it sounds like you're the caliber of
guy that's gonna step up and do this
and tell me if i'm wrong man if you're
not then man you've heard me say a
million times on this show tell your
parents no forget you guys you don't get
a vote you're out
sister you don't get a vote i'm taking
my other kidney i'm going home
you're free to do that man it's your
body
but i hear that character hesitation in
your heart because i think you know what
you're going to do
am i right sure yeah
so what's your hesitancy
just uh i mean unfortunately if
financial you know i it's it requires
uh the money that's gonna take me
to a different state um i'll be out of
work you know
i've just in the past year uh
you know just with the craziness i've
been laid off twice um and we're just
now
getting into a position where we're
we're starting to climb out of a big
hole
um with that um and it's just uh
i mean as much as i don't want to admit
you know money is
is part of my decision because i
you know i have a wife that's relying on
me i you know i
i have responsibilities um
and it's it's all being taken into
consideration
hey it's hey it should okay it
absolutely should be taken into
consideration
and don't feel bad about putting the
nuts and bolts on this thing it's cool
to be all courageous and yeah here i
come to save the day but man you're
exactly right there's a financial toll
to pay you're going to be out of work
you may have just picked up a third job
you're in a tough tough economy in
anchorage right now
right and that's when you may have to
swallow some pride and get on the phone
and call some folks to help you out
and that may be asking your mom and dad
to help out or if you've got other
brothers and sisters to help out
and there may be nobody there man there
may be nobody to answer that call
and um
i don't want to make it sound like it's
going to be easy i'm trying to put
myself in your situation right now i
have an older sister too and if she
hollered at me and said hey
a kidney you mean you know what i would
be i would know i was going to do it you
know what i would be
scared to death
i'd be scared to death that it didn't
work i'd be scared that i only got one
left
i'd be scared that i've got two little
kids that i want to make sure i can run
around with
and i want you to know um it's okay to
be scared
to death that you're gonna undergo a
pretty serious surgery to remove
part of your body right it's not a minor
thing
and you're gonna do it out of character
you're gonna do it out of
the deepest love there is for other
people have you talked to your sister
how does that conversation go man
uh we haven't spoken in years
so let's start there you start there
adrian will you call your sister today
and just tell her hey i love you i love
you and i heard you're hurting
and tell me what's going on
yeah because i think that's the place to
start
just connect your heart back to your
sisters and she may tell you
screw you adrian i want your stupid body
part and maybe you're all the way off
the hook dude
probably not but i want you to go first
having characters hard man doing the
right thing is so hard
and oh man
love comes with so much risk and so much
pain and so much
what if what if man and then here we are
and then you have cisgame talk too in
years
but i have a feeling man if someone that
you worked with you'd be that guy that
stepped up and if it was
your brother-in-law you'd step up and if
it was
somebody at your church you'd step up i
think you're that guy man
and if you're not hear me say to your
body
you feel free to do what you want to do
but i don't want you to backtrack and
say well i'm not going to because
in the past she fill in the blank or my
mom is really making me no man
the heat of this decision rests in your
heart
and in your character do this because
you got to do this because it's the
right thing to do do it because it's
hard hard and you're that kind of guy do
it because
when you have two or three or four
knucklehead little kids running around
your sister is going to be back in your
life and she's going to tell them you
know what your daddy did for me
and that's the kind of man he is man
that's that's that's a story you tell
your kids right
um that leads me to this i've got um
here's this is that yeah this is it
um so
you've heard me talk a lot about this um
and usually i talk about it again
making jokes about it about hey it's
hard to have hard conversations
and it's hard to make wills it's hard
because everyone's faced with hard
conversations
and everybody passes away and i was
thinking over the weekend
i got to stop making jokes about that
sometimes it's hard
right i come from a family we talk about
death all the time in passing that's not
normal it's probably not even healthy um
but life is full of hard conversations
and these really harsh
realities and if we're loving our family
we're gonna talk about
hard things like hey man i would love
to help out here we haven't talked in
years we've been estranged from one
another you don't take care of yourself
help me help you right that's a hard
conversation hey mom
i know you love your daughter and i
love her too and i'm working on it but
how about you
back off a little bit um hey honey i
love you and we have three little kids
but one day we're gonna pass away and
we gotta have a will we've got to do
this stuff because it's going to happen
this
all under this umbrella of how to have
hard conversations
if you will text legacy to 33789
that's legacy to 33789
we're gonna talk it's just um it's
something here that the ramsey folks
created about how to have hard
conversations how to talk about
making a will how to talk about these
hard conversations that you
and your wife need to have and if you're
not even married yet how you and your
future partner can have these
conversations but
man we've just done it three times on
the show hard conversation after hard
conversation after heart conversation
that's the life that we live in
um and the better we can get having
those hard conversations being honest
with one another
not the easier life's gonna be but man
it just begins to pull away these bricks
of weight so we can handle these things
with light feet
on a firm foundation so um adrian man
we'll be thinking about you here's the
deal adrian
i'm i'm asking am i gonna beg i got
close just then
i wanna know how this conversation goes
with your sister and i wanna know what
you decide
shoot me an email back and i'm gonna
read it out over the show or we may call
you back because i'd love to know how
that conversation goes and what you
ultimately decide
all right so as we wrap up today's show
again i want to say thank you to
the audience y'all are awesome
zach james kelly we're going to make a
hard transition here because i only got
one song
and uh probably wouldn't have been the
song i chose for this show but here we
go anyway we're gonna
we're gonna flip the switch i texted
some buddies
my old buddies chris and caleb and i
said caleb i need a song
and he said uh there's just one choice
it's 1983 i don't even know if he was
alive then i think he was
1983 record can't slow down was the name
of the record
is the one and only lionel richie
singing his classic they got booties are
shaking all over
the globe it's called all night long and
he sings
well my friends the time has come to
raise the roof and have some fun
we're done raising the roof by the way
but oh lionel can
throw away the work to be done let the
music play on play on play
on everybody's seeing everybody dance
lose yourself
in a wild romance we're gonna party
caramel
fiesta forever come on and sing along
people dancing all in the street see the
rhythm all in their feet life is good
wild and sweet
let the music play on play on play
on all night long all night
night all night long here on the dr john
dolone show